ciao caro vito ricevuto un massaggiatore
forma di york a voi questo delicatissimo
profumo carlini carlin playing ciao
ragazzi bentornati a una nuova puntata
di vita buttata qui sul mio canale vita
buttata è un format molto semplice ogni
tanto io vi chiedo online di farmi
sapere qual è la vostra opinione
riguardo un tema in particolare quello
di questa volta è regali di merda per un
tema così importante ho deciso di
mettere così all'interno dei grandi
studios di questo sgabuzzino nel quale
sono stanco e rapito una persona
importante gli amici sono come dei
regali alcuni sono graditi altri pochino
di meno
matteo bruno matteo senti parte con i
regali di merda è già qualcosa di tuo o
vogliamo subito partire con i messaggi e
magari non si facciamo rompere il
ghiaccio agli altri regali di merck
javier emo e regalo che brutta mi abbia
mai ricevuto è stato un telo mare con
borsa abbinata regalato uno dei miei
cugini per il mio compleanno
fin qui tutto bene penserai ma io sono
al vino e non posso vendere il sole che
regata di merda però ma non te ne
accorgi
non è un problema di posai o un ernia e
non stavo bene natale con apparente si è
presentata con una confezione merendine
e neanche incartate ma la cosa più
brutta è stata vedere che erano scadute
da te ne eri veramente è stato per ora
tristezza voglio tirare dietro a mio zio
nel 2014 mi legherò un calza scarpe che
terminava con la testa di un cavolo con
calzascarpe oggi viene usato per scavare
la terra nei mazzi arpino una roba
questo è stato il regalo che la migliore
amica di mia madre gli ha fatto lo
scorso anno non sappiamo ancora cosa sia
è un problema che guarda che bello che
forme delicate che colori ricercati
io l'ho desidererei molto qui sul mio
tavolo per lavorare tutti i giorni mi
hanno regalato una testa di cavallo in
gesso ottimo dimensioni quasi naturali
senza un orecchio perché perché chi me
lo aveva regalato era caduto dalle
schifezze atto mela e quindi rompendo
mela era il destino ciao avute guidate
menegazzo
cade no si è rotto mannaggia
vabbè tieni senza un orecchio brutto che
ha ricevuto io stata una bambola di
porcellana che tuttora nella mia stanza
si sta parlando la bambola di porcellana
efficiente
questa persona è piccola cosa ma quando
parlano dei locali vedi salta sul tasto
d'epoca e di conseguenza è lontana dalla
migrazione
io vorrei fare un appello a tutte quante
le ragazze che là fuori hanno ricevuto
una bambola di porcellana da qualcuno
c'è almeno una fra di voi che l'ho
apprezzato come adriano perché è bello
agli occhi spiritati come mi piace
questo velo di morte che comunica io per
tutta una serie di natali ho ricevuto
dei regali da donna e perché e non lo so
io non ho mai capito
sì ma però un radio ha ben deciso di
recarmi carne e sempre batterà palle
gratis
è questo il bello di carne un'altra cosa
che mi piace tantissimo come idea la mia
nonna banale mal di resi le fina questa
donna che pesava 40 kg per ogni tanto
una fettina di carne e io dicevo si
quasi solo per vedere questo batticarne
si sfogava anni di ira funesta su questo
povero animale morto in merito regali di
merda qualche anno fa regala ai uno
shampoo specifico per i capelli biondi a
mio padre impacchettato con il giornale
facendo una palla di scotch a regola
d'arte
mio padre calvo circa 45 anni a mia zia
mi regalò un sacco di cose per il gatto
tipo croccantini le fiere
collarini tutte queste cose qui gatto
era morto cinque giorni prima che fosse
invisibile quanto cattivo gusto quanto
giallo si può generare in una situazione
del genere ha inviato rassicura uno dei
regali ricevuti nei miei genitori per
questo natale e come puoi vedere è
esattamente un pezzo di legno e niente
più di un pezzo di legno nel quale erano
state conosciute 4 candeline a parte
l'orrore estetico abbastanza evidente
noterai quanto sia un poco intelligente
utilizzare un po di legna carriera per
lì che è arrivato gli infermieri amore
vogliamo fare della serata sarà spesso
questo non verrà mai messo però per il
nostro gusto personale
il regalo di compleanno fatto la mia
amica lucia si è un sex toys con me il
fatto che un avvitatore
[Applauso]
a queste video e arte qualsiasi momento
barbieri marzo il suono che si gira
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video io vi ringrazio per tutti i
messaggi che avete mandato ma
soprattutto mi chiedo scusa perché non
sono riuscito ad ascoltarli tutti alla
prima volta che me ne arrivano così
tanti che non riescono
fatemi sapere qua sotto se volete tipo
una parte 2
magari ecco per non sprecare tutti quei
messaggi perché ce ne sono un sacco
io ringrazio matteo razzetti purtroppo
ci ha lasciato
ringrazio naturalmente la sleepbox per
avermi permesso di girare con i loro
mezzi
questo sgabuzzino senza dover alzare un
mignolo per una volta è naturalmente
come sempre più a un appuntamento al
prossimo video
se non volete perderli premete il
pulsante per riscrivere che qua sotto se
l'avete già fatto
accendete le notifiche in modo da
seguire tutto quanto vi do un bacio e un
abbraccio grandissimo al prossimo video
ciao stai meglio sto benissimo
ciao ciao